[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Lizzy
kicks us off in Austin Texas Lizzie
welcome to the
show hi thank you for taking my call I
just found out I was I'm pregnant with a
our miracle baby that in on Friday wowow
wait a second how why how is this a
miracle baby give us the
story because unfortunately we've had
two miscarriages in the past 13 months
oh and we were actually going to start
doing IVF we'll save up for IVF but we
actually got back into the FPU and we're
like you know what we're going to put
that to the side and let's just tackle
all the debt because we have an
overwhelming amount of debt um mainly
business debt but because everything is
personal collateral I just think it's
all personal debt anyway you would be
correct you're right your name's on it
well congratulations
exciting Avenue my husband because I
don't even know I feel like I can't even
be excited you told us before your
husband you told you you told these two
clowns and millions of other people
before him I hope he's in a hole
somewhere safely that he can't hear this
when do you plan on telling
him I'm planning to tell him for
Christmas because I do want to I have
been doing the blood work and everything
just to make sure everything's going
good and that um we don't have an
unfortunate event again I think this is
a good idea I I don't think it's a good
idea to put this out there on the show
and then wait until Christmas to tell
him I'd sit him down tonight with a
smile on your face and say listen I know
we've been through a lot you're not
going to believe this but here you go I
feel like we should conference call him
in and tell him right now I that's what
I think yeah I wouldn't wait for the myy
moment for him to go you are the father
yeah I'd go ahead and tell him
now okay but that's just two guys
opinion actually gonna meet him here
probably in about an hour before he goes
into work that's a lot for you to carry
that's like your little secret for next
10 days listen I I I I want to get to
the debt stuff but I've got to say you
have got to tell him today before he
gets into the off you can't you I feel
guilty like I'm I'm a mess right now our
live studio audience is in a g they
don't know what to do either don't you
all feel like I so we should tell this
guy I can't bear this this burden is too
heavy
the funny thing is too is that he
predicted it about three weeks ago and
I'm like no there's no way and it's too
soon anyway and turns out he was right
well that's what you sit him down and
say this guy called a shot hey honey
your crystal ball was correct you'll
never believe it okay this is the
craziest thing that's ever happened to
me on the show George that's pretty wild
all right well it's an honor that you
trusted us with this secret and millions
of listeners let me gather myself Lizzy
The reason I feel like we can't be
excited or I can't be excited is because
we have 50,000 50.5 th000 um in personal
like personal Bill debt on top of that
we have
6515 th000 of business debt that is all
tied to our personal oh my God what kind
of business debt is it construction debt
and it's um anywhere from credit cards
to to personal loans to uh the 80% of it
is probably friends family I say friends
and family but honestly it's more like
lone sharks well it sounds like your
friends and family made a bad
Investments is this business still
afloat is it doing well where is it it
it is doing well in the sense of like so
and it's combined dead of my business
with my business which is also um a
construction business but I keep wanting
to sit I'm down that that's the other
issue too is that I keep wanting to sit
them down and talk numbers but it just
ends up being a big ordeal or we get
into an argument and we just can't seem
to come eye to eye and I've showed them
like the plan of what I because uh I we
started doing FPU again and I'm doing
the everyday dollar not only I got the
everyday Black Friday deal um a dollar
Black Friday deal for the personal
finances and then on top of that I'm
also for the business so I got two two
of them what is the and then what's the
household
income the household income for just my
husband and I with his W2 income my W2
income and the business income is about
18,300 a month a month a month and
that's
gross and that's gross that's what we
take home yes okay are you guys paying
your taxes are you putting money aside
for that how's that working so and
that's the other thing uh included in
the in the numbers I gave you that were
in debt I'm assuming right now we
probably owe about 15 to $16,000 worth
of taxes okay that's going to go to the
top of the
gosh that's going to be the first thing
you pay off is the IRS debt and then
we're going to continue on down smallest
to largest balance this is going to be
years and years of
sacrifice one quick question on this you
said W2 W2 so this company that's got
the $600,000 in debt is that separate
from your day jobs your normal jobs so
that's separate from our day jobs my
husband already Works 14 to 16 hour days
six days a week and I do the same thing
on top of that on top of that I like
that's including me managing the
construction company um who's who's
working for you when you say manage the
construction company and you're working
14 to 16 hour days who are you
managing I am managing we have a group
of I we used to well I own one I used to
have about 15 people I cut it down to
about eight uh I weeded out the people
that I feel like instead of making me
money it I'm putting I'm putting money
to okay so you're like a general
contractor essentially I'm a general
contractor yes and you're and you're
both working 14 to 16 hours a day
correct is there any collateral that you
guys could sell as part of this business
equipment is it real estate yeah this is
going to take a decade to get out of at
this rate well um I did I crunched the
numbers and if my if I put 12500 towards
the business debt and my dad puts 1200
towards the business debt will be done
in 2018 mon your dad is half partner in
all of this well the the 651 half of it
is his however well I say his rhetoric I
don't want what's the correct word
because at the end of the day it's under
my name the out of that probably only
20% is under his name so no matter what
I have to PID but he's paying half this
is like a common core math question
Lizzie we got to sort this all out and
I'm excited for the baby but you're
right we got a mess on our hands it's
going to take some drastic choices for
probably 5 to 10 years to clean this up
but I hope it's faster than that we are
wishing you guys the best congrats on
the baby tell him today please don't let
him find out from this show this is the
ramsy show create your free every dooll
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life